this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone welcome to the 2023 hemp
webinar series
uh it's nice to see you all back here my
name is Luis monsarate I'm a second year
PhD student in plumbing and genetics in
a very small Corner University
and I organized in this webinar with the
help of a called excuse me
Tony baraco who you can see here
the video first of all I would like to
acknowledge the main the amazing working
help
um of Kim who put all of this digital
infrastructure together for all of us to
have this great webinar today so thank
you so much Kim
um before we get started there are a few
orders of business I would like to cover
so please
um be patient with me so there will be
two buttons that you'll be using along
this talk as well as in the next
um webinars there is a q a button in the
chat button
please make sure to use the Q a button
uh to enter your questions to the speak
for a speaker and for any other kind of
dialogue that you would like to have
with the other attendees or with the
speakers
uh or with us please use a chat button
lastly I want to point out that this
webinar Series has a slight twist this
year each of these webinars is a
component of eight educational modules
so each module will consist of a
recorded webinar which is one of them
gonna be the one that you are seeing
right now an instruction on a slide Deck
with more of a teaching style that will
be
um developed by the speaker
in a set of high impact papers
pertaining to the respective subject of
educational module so in this case this
education module is called botany and
physiology
these modules will be fully available
sorry
um on the Cornell ham website and at the
end of the webinar series for anyone
interested in re-watching this webinar
series or interestingly learning more
about hamping alone
um anyways so with that allow me to
introduce the speaker today's speaker is
Dr Aaron Siebert he's a research
associate professor in the department of
biological environmental Sciences at
Alabama a m University and the topic of
his talk today is exploring Industrial
Hemp 25 potential new applications at
Alabama a m University
so without further Ado please talk to
receiver take it away
okay uh thank you
uh Louis why don't you give me a thumbs
up if you can hear me very well
very good thank you uh good afternoon
everyone
and uh as Louis said
um
Ernst Siebert of faculty member at
Alabama University and uh the very first
slide is simply should show exactly
where we do our work at a research
station uh uh in uh in Huntsville
Alabama this is actually in Hazel Green
Alabama so uh
the first point I'd like to make in
making this presentation is to show that
Alabama is very unique in a sense that
we have uh
in a sense that we have three language
independent universities no they're not
they're Simply Connected because there
are land grant institutions but there
are independent uh
institutions and because of that we have
to be very careful how the kind of
research that we do any kind of federal
funding uh
that's provided traditional state and
federal funding is uh given with the
concept in mind of not duplicating
projects so it makes it somewhat very uh
unique for us to uh work together as
three independent institutions uh so as
far as Alabama a m is concerned
I had another slide there that missed
there was our research station slide
that shows where we have uh all the work
that we do here we do it in uh about a
Thousand Acre research station uh that's
about 10 miles north of the University
where we do all of our work uh the
research station is subdivided into
crops uh Horticulture type of work uh
animal work and and uh of course we were
so the topic of today since uh we were
supposed to
mention and not mention actually to
focus on certain aspects of Botanical uh
the Botanical makeup of the Cannabis uh
uh genus and the various uh
species that are associated with it we
we don't I know everyone who's probably
listening to this talk know the history
of cannabis here uh in the U.S and
possibly around the world one of the
most uh
ancient crop as far as cultivation for
use of food for use of medicine and uh
for uh for use of materials and so on so
currently uh as we explored we
introduced subscribe in our myth for
research uh and for our consumer uh
product and so on the renewed interests
a great deal of attention is being paid
to the Botanical aspect of this plant
style the sativa the indica and with the
relation and the hybrids of the
the hybrids of the uh of these three
actually make up the realest uh uh well
make up the uh a different
brand of the
of the genus that we are uh that we're
now being privy to and as we collect
more and more uh samples from around the
world as we collect samples to do our
work our concentration is mostly an uh
uh THC the psychoid psychoactive
compound and also the non-cycle active
compound the cannabinoid which with
medicinal properties and all the type of
uh potential characteristic of the plant
properties of the plant that we can use
uh that we have to explore to see how
they can be uh put into a consumer
product and use now of course and and
dealing with the plants we have to
understand the various forms that we
have uh that's gonna we're gonna come in
in contact with uh the Malaysia's type
the diacious type and
hermaphrodic types so we in the early
days or we we are in the early days of
understanding the plant again in the
research sphere so we have to be dealing
with all these type of Botanical
specification on a regular process so uh
let me do something here
so again uh to continue
showing that
these are probably your primary interest
that the
public is interested in when it comes to
cannabis as it began to
opened up the legality of it just began
to open up across the country uh it's
still
uh uh it's still in the hand of uh the
federal government to actually open it
up completely so therefore uh in our
research world we don't really have to
worry about whether we're above a
certain range of THC uh uh or not but
nonetheless with the new with rules that
existing today of a specific specific
level of THC so as long as we remain at
that level we know that to be able to uh
focus on this type of cannabinoid get a
great deal of progress is being made
right now across the country so in in
the process
we here at a m we do a great deal of
work with uh other colleagues across the
country and this uh this is actually a
slide from one of our partners from uh
Oregon State University uh Dr Jeffrey
Steiner where is emphasizing the uh the
future of these type of cannabinoid is
to over time that we will see
the
a greater uh
marketing strategy that can be developed
mentally because of
The increased production to increase
interest The increased uh demand for
these products so right now we know that
the very first few years of growing uh
essential oil hemp for CBD
the market is already down here okay the
market is already down here because of
an over abundance of crop that was
produced within the last uh within the
last uh few years since 2014 uh from the
2014 farm bill so but of course the
point that was being made here for uh by
Dr Cerner is that the science must come
before the market so this is where then
we are focusing on trying to understand
the science of the crop so here is a
a slide showing some of uh an rcbd
design of uh six cultivars of hemp that
we receive from uh Oregon State and uh
it's uh
let me see if I can remove my uh
something's hiding my slides here okay
yeah it shows that at Oregon State
University they're up there at near 45
degrees north latitude and then we're
down here 34 and uh where we are in
Huntsville so
dare gold at the global hip Innovation
Center was to go across the 45 degree
latitude around the world and collect
samples that they know that would sort
of uh
adapt to their region so once they get
some of these uh entries some some of
them they send to us down here in uh in
Huntsville at this different latitude
and to begin to look into the potential
adaptation of this thing in our in our
area so what are we doing with these
things well when we receive them
okay when we when should we receive them
uh
throughout the growing season we collect
a series of data which uh we'll show in
a minute and then eventually uh once we
Harvest uh these plants we go through a
series of post-harvest uh uh uh analysis
and data collection and then once we
collect all the information we then send
the floral material to uh Oregon and
they do all the cannabinoid analysis why
we do all the phenotypical
characterization here in our area
they will do their G by uh G by E type
of analysis with labinoid and uh or
phenotypic data so this is uh the
process that we followed and this is an
example of
what we do during our ultimate season uh
we're looking at some Four Season uh
entries uh uh uh versus some other CBD
type and we do the plant height uh the
same diameters the enforcements weight
dry weight and all this type of data we
do this is data actually from uh 2020
but we've been doing it you know 2021
2022 so on a regular basis this type of
characteristic is showing us which among
the culture of our data uh sent to us
here in uh in Huntsville that actually
can be recommended for growers in in our
region uh for their production uh mainly
and based on those phenotypic
characteristic and the final yield of
these characteristics but uh uh final
data with the essential oil uh will be
shared uh with us from Oregon state from
the Labs so now
to show all the other uh
we take advantage of having these uh
of having these culture bars here to do
other type of work for instance this
slide is simply showing uh to one of our
professors uh Dr Senor and his student
where
that feel the picture I just showed you
earlier where they actually came when we
first play uh when we first planted it
as we're about to plant it and RCB uh
set up they came into a collection of
samples randomly select some location
where the plants will are planted and
collect soil samples and did analysis
for metal and then they waited until the
end of the season came again the same
location uh harvested the plants uh and
then takes more soil sample and then to
run the show sample to actually see uh
are there certain type of metal
accumulation and components of the
plants and the reason we're doing this
is because here in uh Alabama we have
this side at least in Northern Alabama
we have a red uh clay a star that tends
to uh sometimes be on the acidic side uh
and then the acidic side will actually
will make some of these Metals become
bioavailable for uptake and well then
what is where do they go when the uptake
occur so it and this these slides are in
two and two cultivar that we have a
queen dream and uh a photo CBD entry
that these metals are accumulating and
The Roots and the stems and then the
leaves uh uh the RS and L here represent
that so uh the pH where we did this work
was definitely on the acidic side about
now 5.4 uh uh pH so therefore that's
enough to see that these uh metals are
being
sequestered by the plant without showing
any detrimental side uh impact uh during
the process of uh of the life cycle of
the plant so we this process is ongoing
so we have more information about this
that we really later on further on
since we partnered with the team in
Geneva New York Dr stencil and his team
with pgru group we are following the
very specific uh
protocol from the descriptor uh handbook
to on samples that are sent to us for
the uh from the diverse uh germ plasma
up there in in Geneva so we have two
sets of uh of uh approach for for this
where we're focusing based on the
archetype of the plant where there's a
single stem that's not with very uh uh
minimal branching we focus on the stem
and then if however the plant has a
different archetype we actually focus on
a complete kite-like characteristic
measuring various uh uh uh growth
patterns of the plant by uh looking at
branching height uh the maximum canopy
diameter and so on uh the height at mid
point of the plant and then also uh
trunk length stem diameter and to see
how all of these contribute to the final
product that we're looking for in uh in
the app so so far are we are we are
seeing uh
we are seeing those phenotypic
characteristic and how they correlate
with the one aspect of the plant that we
probably most interested in is the uh
the dry mass production and then with
the dry mass production in terms of
height and term of uh number of branches
and stem diameter uh in the in in a key
one that shows the the difference there
is the the distance of the first no of
the first branch which of course is uh
uh a related uh to uh which can be
directly related to uh uh the population
of the plots so the the more the
population the more dense about applied
is therefore the higher up the first
Branch uh uh are but then the first
branches are so but of course uh we see
plants that even though they're they do
not they're not in a very crowded
position sometimes the first Branch tend
to be much higher up basically so of
course for fiber we would see the
very minimal branches uh uh being being
uh
produced by the plant while for the CBD
oil type of uh the essential oil uh when
it's grown for cannabinoid the female
plants only of course they're branching
now started as low as possible from our
experience here so this was just an
example of two different entries that we
received from uh from New York from
Geneva uh entry one entry two and we're
seeing a very same pattern uh being uh
being uh being exerted uh based on those
measurement from the hemp descriptor
that we're receiving now this
first set of slide that I showed you
here is probably what we're doing the
most women comes to a high cannabinoid
uh hemp here at uh at Alabama a m
University and then of course as you can
see it is with the collaboration with
other partners uh across the country
uh with Oregon State uh with uh with
Geneva New York with the new as the
s1084 group and University of uh
Kentucky but this next set of slide that
I'm going to show you is basically of
what we have been doing here in our end
more independently than uh again with a
collaboration with others but still that
we are initiating
here at Alabama a m University so we
have a great deal of internal colleague
at the at the University from biology
food and animal science a College of
Engineering and then also with other uh
institutions that I mentioned that we're
also also partnering with so what what
remember 2019 was when Alabama as a
state first allowed the production of
hemp whether it's by universities or or
or
public uh Growers
extractors and it didn't matter we're
just right after the 2018 Farm Bill the
state simply jumped to the process and
it was sort of very chaotic uh were we
ready well no we weren't ready we didn't
know truly how to approach it but so we
were the first one here in the state to
begin the process of putting some
experimental plots on the ground so we
we tried planning with a drill
uh then we try broadcasting we in the
broadcasting we realized we had to do
some rolling to uh uh to create uh some
uh compaction of the seed into the soil
and
waited with our fingers crossed with our
high learning curve to see what's going
to happen next so
this is sort of an example of what
happened next we the the seeds that we
broadcast we learned very quickly that's
a No-No uh because
every single one of those seeds became
bird food our uh our research station is
actually a refuge for Birds where
birders come to uh to take pictures and
look at various type of birds and we're
not supposed to hurt the birds but the
birds definitely ate all of our seeds uh
doves and others uh basically all the
birds seem to love hemp seed so we lost
that so we did some planting using a
small haggy experimental plot I know
this is not a very good picture of it
but this is uh
uh in attempt of uh you'll see much
better pictures of this of planting with
a small higgy and then this is the area
where we planted with uh with the drill
and very quickly this is just maybe uh
five to six days after planting uh seven
days after planting we begin to receive
very good uh
quality seedlings emerging but at the
same time we saw this this is morning
glory this is the Nemesis of hemp and
then we shortly in this presentation
you'll see what I mean by that so uh
having these spots
that 2019 we were able to obtain eight
culture barge and it was just a
it was just a Mad Dash for people trying
to get a Siege you don't know where uh
where you were getting your seeds from
who the whether those people were
legitimate uh the information that
they're giving you uh and so on the Seas
of course the information were vetted by
the state because the state had to
approve every single culture bar that we
planted so we had a we had a pseudo
planting date experiment not because we
planned it it's because that's when we
received the seeds we received seeds of
genma on June the 4th June the fifth
we're on the field planning it we
received these seeds on June 18th uh
more seeds on June 18th four different
cultivars so we added uh the general
with the other four new full culture bar
that we received and then continue to do
this each time we receive other culture
bars so as you can see our planting date
from June 5th to July 11th just uh more
a month apart
definitely told us a lot he told us that
that's too late to plant the quad uh uh
genma did very well
as opposed to many of the others which
did not fare well at all this to poor
germination nauseous type of seeds uh
that uh that did not uh that react
responded to uh more to for the period
very quickly so therefore we learned
very recall here in the first year
on our learning curve some of the do's
and don'ts uh that we have to uh avoid
so again but nonetheless we took
advantage of this and continue to make
observation on continuous basis
by the time we get to day 86 we saw that
uh
you know by the time we get to day 86 we
uh these plants were already at more
than 50 percent male flowering which is
recommended if you're cutting if you are
planting for uh fiber it's a good time
to do it so we did Harvest uh the
significant Harvest of those uh Gemma
line that we have and then allow them to
uh sit on the field for rating and then
went on further to pay uh to collect
more information the learning curve uh
that at the same time this is an example
of one of our planting date earlier
planting date a second planting data so
another planting date here at the day
that we're replacing it we were now a
little eggy planner a sexual
experimental planner and a downpour
thunderstorm Cam that uh produced so
much rain that we had standing water
there for a day or more and we can see
that there's certain area that never
really recovered fully uh recovered from
uh
from being underwater with the root
being saturated which then automatically
tells us that you you select your plot
selection has to be out
well-drained area where you know the
root of your plant is not going to be
saturated uh with water because it's not
it will not perform very well so this is
again another view of that year where
our genma uh did uh very well
considering that was planted late uh and
then our on the bottom uh a lift
pictured as the the
the rcbd design of those eight culture
bars a different date still all the
better looking plots you see here you
know uh represent a Denmark ultravart
where the others did that number as well
we also observe all other necessary
information that we needed to uh
anything we see we recorded whether it
was qualitative or quantitative to begin
to get an idea uh uh and a picture of
what we're dealing with when it comes to
uh to the to this particular crop we can
see a nice beneficial insect here but
not a very so beneficial in the upper
right hand where you see the uh a
sucking uh insect that can cause but
again since this is the
the
male flower we weren't really concerned
about the presence of certain
uh Tom Ford insect because they're not
really damaging a part it's going to be
very useful as we go in the plant as
long as these plants produce their
pollen if if you're growing for Siege
then we have we don't think that these
kind of Nemesis would cause uh would
cause issue our primary concern however
uh the good guys the those bees we have
probably 50 or more uh beehives at our
research station and those bees do
forage the male cannabis plant
significantly as you can see with uh
taking pollens back to their hives and
uh we actually the the apiary faults
that we work with they actually put some
drawers where an entry point at the
entry point where the bees return to the
hive where that pollen can actually be
squipped off and fall into the uh into a
drawer that can be now collected to see
the constituent of this pollen so this
is the type of work that we try to do
and now we saw the opportunity and go
for that now what's the number one
Nemesis I was telling about well we weed
is definitely the issue as you can see
from we followed the process of our uh
the first year when we planted when
there were no chemical uh that was
allowed to even use on the hemp and we
quickly uh realized the problem that you
have and planting very late uh June July
where the local weed species are already
in full-fledged ready to uh uh to to
germinate and uh and reproduce so
therefore the hemp did not have an
opportunity to create a canopy a full
canopy to actually overshadow or even
compete with those weeds so that was the
a major uh learning experience and then
the other one was
even the statement I just made about
having a good canopy to overshadow uh uh
undergrowth of the canopy that didn't
happen here this is a picture of the
same Field July 31st August 24th just we
talked in less than 30 days and then
this is what became of this field it was
a beautiful flowering feel instead of a
beautiful hemp feel and at this stage
the bottom picture is a complete loss
because uh you can't even uh even if
seeds were produced here you can even
take a combine there to uh to to harvest
the seed so this is a slide that we
really like to uh uh we like to uh show
to Growers who said this expect this to
happen if you don't have a weed control
management system so we also have uh an
issue that happened I believe in 2020 or
2021 when that 2020 when we had a uh and
infestation of army earworm and but in
their case they were focusing on
consuming the essential oil this is some
of the entries from an entry from
cannabinary plot we entries from Oregon
and these as you can see this is the
video doesn't show you the whole uh
aspect I was trying to get a close-up
and you can see all the other areas of
the particular Leaf that's already been
consumed uh by this little crater right
here so we definitely
we definitely think that this is uh I
mean there are people right now already
working on that uh down at Auburn our
friend now at Auburn they are already
looking into protocol to overcome this
type of situation uh that that can be
devastating so I'll go back so again
these are the data uh from that very
first year that uh we collected again we
talk about General uh July 5th July 19
and uh June 19 and July 11th 19 and to
see the productivity uh in biomass uh uh
and then uh the growth of the height the
world pattern of these things and we
think that all these uh also have to do
the planting date which also relates to
photo period
so as the days get shorter during uh
during these uh the production the
latter stages of production of these of
biomass production of these plants we
see that they also quickly revert uh uh
transition into reproduction in a not
much biomass production at due to Labor
Day we uh we thank our idea of planting
date should be very early in the spring
probably as early as uh as a late April
uh I mean uh mid-april even late March
that we can actually start the planting
process here most most likely mid-april
would be a good thing so as you can see
all the other varieties that we planted
that here did not do well at all those
monocious type uh uh they they simply
reacted to a photo period situation
immediately uh began a transition into a
flowering mode a reproductive mode with
very little biomass being produced at
all those if you recall this earlier
pictures next to the genma those were
those other culture bars so we've since
stayed away from these as much as we can
because we know that they do not do
perform well here in our area
no I'm just gonna very quickly sort of
show some uh various uh
work that we're trying to do because we
have the hemp to see if we can take
advantage of this uh uh to to have a
better understanding of the problem we
know the physiological process of
germination a lot of the seeds that we
receive uh uh some of them have very
poor germination and uh therefore we
took it up we we took up an experiment
of exposing uh our hemp seed to a low
temperature plasma you know very good
question why you do this well we just
happen to have a a collaborative Grant
with the University of uh Huntsville
Alabama uh on the f-sport grant uh to uh
at the bottom or lower uh lower right
here the acronym is uh cpu2al that
stands for connecting the plasma
universe to Alabama so in that case we
saw that low temperature plasma has
multiple function uh in application so
in this project in this project we were
supposed to try to uh see potential all
other application for it and one
successful application was that it
worked very well and enhancing the
germination of two current a rhizome so
we said why not try a hemp also so we
tried uh
with a student to understand the concept
of plasma which is not our field in
agriculture but to come to a point to
understand it and then basically it's
the uh an iron ionization process of uh
of an inner gas that we do uh
to helium argon uh with a high voltage
and in the ionization process the ions
that are uh the result of this process
we feel that are able to interact with
other biological surfaces and that's
what the project did we use two
different types of three different types
of plasma exposure a sheet plasma uh a
jet plasma and the Chamber plasma all
these at least the two the sheet in the
jet were stuff that's
uh done at University of Alabama our
engineering department to build this
thing where the chamber one we did at uh
in Birmingham University of Alabama in
Birmingham where uh they have a good
system and what we wanted to see is that
Ken uh increase in the exposure of of
the uh The Siege to the low temperature
plasma whether it's soap not soaked uh
uh would actually provide uh show an
impact in helping enhancing uh or or
speeding up the process of the
germination and also the length of time
you allow the temp the plasma to be
exposed to the seeds seem to have a
major difference because we saw that we
saw that in uh in turmeric at the time
like a 90 second exposure uh has better
result than uh than uh than a 30 second
exposure and even better result than 120
second exposure so therefore we tried
all these with seeds of the uh where we
try to keep track of the exact seeds by
uh uh
exposing single seeds to the process
and our results simply showed that any
seed that we had that's uh that was
soaked 24 hours before and then treated
with the plasma came out as the fastest
one to uh to begin the germination
process those that were soaked and not
treat it at all with the plasma still uh
uh can follow followed the first one and
and so on the the this is this would be
the real control because this is the
seed as we receive it from the in its
package from the source so these seeds
uh they did all right even when they're
treated with the plasma and while the
untreated version uh came out last of uh
as they come across so this is actually
a final slide about this plasma uh uh
response I'm sorry this is a very busy
slide uh we had students doing this
Workforce where they were measuring a
Time measurement of uh of the length of
the the radical uh and then to see that
uh this is variety one variety too
variety3 there's a feminized feminized
seeds seeds that were for CBD uh uh
plantain so we see that there's a
response by a cultivar so therefore that
experiment definitely we have to go back
and repeat it and really uh do more
better control approach to see truly if
exposing a plant to uh the seeds to
plasma can actually make a difference in
enhancing and then uh speeding up the
germination process so but again moving
on we have well I have to move on very
quickly okay uh we we work with our food
science department with Dr Okafor and a
student we're looking at other
nutritional values and characteristics
of looking at flavonoid and phenolic
compounds and uh and and various tissues
of the hemp and we they were able to see
very clear distinction even as showing
by this uh uh by this grouping uh uh
that shows that significantly uh that
the leaves have a greater quantity of
these kind of compounds rather than the
root that's right here at the bottom
very important compounds uh in the
process of nutrition and antioxidant
purposes another that same group at the
biology Department also did some very
good work and taking plant samples uh
hemp samples and then taking pieces of
these hemp samples different tissues
and plating them in different agar and
then to observe what kind of growth that
they're having that's actually
transferred from uh from the plant or to
those plate and their findings again
find provide very good information as to
uh as to what's out there in the field
uh uh that we have to unders we have to
get a better understanding of now one
thing we're seeing here we allow some of
the plant to uh stay in the field in red
uh to for the waiting process and some
of them do allow them to go beyond the
rating process and then to see the kind
of organism uh that becomes more
abundant uh in these tissue samples and
then we we're looking at this hopefully
maybe one day to be able to say we can
create a cocktail of these uh of these
organisms that possibly could help the
rating process make the regular process
a bit faster instead of letting the
plant laying on the field for a long
period of time furthermore this is more
information Nation from that particular
work showing the various uh components
of the plant and the organisms that were
detected uh isolated from them and a lot
of these were
characterized and and authenticated
through DNA analysis so in our food
science department another set of work
that's been done by a a PhD candidate uh
Dr uh I mean Aaron and his advisor Dr
Osama is that they're taking hemp
samples uh enforcing samples and
actually uh during some crude extract
and taking the crude extract and
creating creating some Nano fiber by
Electric spanning with them and then to
be able to put uh create uh sort of food
packaging uh components with them and to
be able to uh uh see if the profile of
the cannabinoid can actually help in
suppressing uh the activity of uh uh
microorganism that normally would be
prolific in some kind of in this poultry
or the food product so this is an
example of the uh the Electro spending
process that that Aaron is doing in the
food science lab I think it's food
engineering lab and then this is an
example of the of the uh
of the product that is created and that
product now is what they would uh
has the encapsulated
nanofiber particles with the active
cannabinoid component again this is a
crude extract with all the profile we're
not is uh there's yet to be worked today
uh to isolate very supposed to uh very
specific cannabinoid to be able to say
this is which one is actually more uh
effective and decreasing the activity of
of uh of these uh dangerous uh organism
in our food system but the result so far
he's seeing that uh versus the control
that they use uh uh uh polyvinyl alcohol
as a control we're seeing is seeing that
there's definitely a benefit these two a
two two A1 to A2 these are different
concentration that is not providing this
consultation yet until he publishes
paper uh so this is uh showing that that
the micro spending uh
uh embedded fibers into that uh into
that packaging material is actually
inhibiting uh uh against salmonella in
the food system so Mr uh uh Aaron
definitely is uh is in the process right
now truly finalizing his uh his uh
dissertation but however with many more
uh uh uh issues to address in uh in the
process we now what else are we doing
well because we're focusing on hemp so
much even the first year we've got all
the information that uh we received from
genma and other cultures are we able to
do some handwriting uh seed uh
uh cleansing seed analysis some herd and
some ham Creek material
now one story about this uh seed after
we cleaned the seed put it to a seed
cleaner and then separate the uh the
under uh unnecessary uh
biomass uh the the biomass that was to
be just jettisoned to to be discarded
was actually used by one of our
professor to uh Dr vizcara to feed
poultry on a skip a day process the
skipper day process is when you don't
feed the the poultry for about a day so
they don't grow too fast during a
breeding uh reading experiment but they
tend to pack each other non-stop so just
by providing them uh what we refer to as
a non-nutritious component they were
able to stay busy and not picking on
each other so we also look at uh these
actually on the right actually came from
uh uh essential oil hemp cultivars that
we collected some stem from a producer
and then ground these stems because
these stems are not very good for
raiding because they have a lot of nodes
and for branching but we still see
potential uses from them so we run them
very well we we use a vibration system
to separate the fiber and then we're
able to pick up a little set of uh fire
a set of fiber this way that clings
together very well and then we actually
had some of these fibers analyzed uh to
uh to see uh sem uh microscopy uh
characteristic of them and the reason
being is that we want to be able to
understand these uh microfibers
so if we're going to use any type of uh
binder to create other products with
them this would give us an idea of what
we're dealing with in the process of uh
trying to create these materials so
now
very quickly this is a an idea of what's
Happening Here at a when it comes to uh
uh when it comes to uh working with
Industrial Hemp we uh a lot of us
everything in yellow is actually active
as being done and uh everything and uh
in some other color yeah well this is
being done also the the cap that's the
packaging work that's being done by Dr
kasama's lab and the bottom one I don't
know I hope you can see it where this is
uh Bob wealth or
omentisi who's doing something that we
call spent him spent hemp is right we
said once the the inversions uh
for the four material are being has
already gone through the processing to
remove all the CBD then that's a
extensive amount of quantity of biomass
that's to be discarded so the idea is
that we we're taking this uh biomass and
actually beginning to pelletize it and
beginning to put it in in the feed for
atoms one of the project that he has
gone in here is to see if those spent
hemp material they would still have
residual carbonoid and adenoids still in
them and actually
or create a relaxation process and uh to
decrease the stress on weaning cattle
when uh when uh cows are being taken
away from their mothers the mothers tend
to be very stressful and then this
experiment is trying to address this
issue of discrete decreasing the stress
so we do have a uh all the other people
in different uh the lighter colors of
people with ideas that you would like to
pursue which we've yet to uh uh to begin
so what else do we do here well
since we have to work with the community
so uh this is a concept again with
Oregon State filers bioscience all of uh
out of Oregon they send us some seeds uh
from philos and then we actually
distribute uh the seeds to uh local uh
grows people with interest all these
people are people with license uh to uh
from this permit with the state to grow
uh to grow hemp so but very small
acreage and then we were giving we gave
each uh participant a certain amount of
seeds of these culture of ours and then
the the to show you how important that
this thing is this is just as few seeds
that you see sitting on the table
there's about 45 000 worth of seeds of
material so it's then difficult to get
into this program so this is why we call
it the uh the hemp Equity program trying
to get people started in the process we
do teach these people so we bring in uh
experts who know these things to come
and speak about it so these people can
have a good start a good beginning in
the Pro in the process of uh
transitioning into him and uh
at this point
I think I would say thank you thank you
very much if I know there are questions
uh probably in the Q a or in the chat uh
uh finish this proposal at uh with a I
mean this uh uh this uh presentation
with a slide of our uh Pond here at our
research station uh in which I I always
make sure if there's a good good Sunset
I don't miss the picture so uh uh please
thank you very much
great presentation to receivers thank
you so much for it's amazing talk and
yes we do have several questions
um so let's see we can get through all
of them before the end of the hour
um
will Dr Silver agree that THC also has
medicinal benefits in addition to CBD
oh yeah I would say uh well again I'm
not a person who've done any kind of
experimental work and such uh clinical
aspect but uh I did serve in the
committee here at the state level and in
their attempt to uh legalize medical
cannabis instead of Alabama and then in
the process all the experts who came to
testify and in front of that committee
uh did there were people with very good
information to support the fact that yes
the THC does have its role in in uh in a
world of Medicine
and and also the cannabinoids yes
next question do you think that we may
change the sex statue of plants through
manipulating the environmental
conditions
the the the sex functions feminine uh
female uh
actually
there are proposals out there addressing
this issue uh to be able to
uh
a with the use of crispr that exists
right now and then identifying those
very specific uh sex genes uh in the
plant the possibility of being able to
uh manipulate to have very uh specific
seeds that we can say that we know that
this uh this plant is only going to be a
female scene this is one of your male
see that that's down the road I believe
has there been any work done to observe
metal accumulation in the flowers
well uh
well I believe that in every state
There are rules and regulation that you
have to analyze for metal and
fluorescence if it's going to be a
consumable of some kind but in our case
here we will do this we will uh being
that we see this high level of
accumulation uh and the leaves and uh in
the stem and The Roots so we we are
going to pay close attention to the
enforcements and uh in the next couple
of seasons
are you excuse me are you also taking
data on the percentage of terpene deal
each cultivar produces or just focusing
on phytocannabinoids
we're not doing any chirping work at all
right now uh we know that's very
important because that's a an extremely
important component of the final product
of uh uh of these cannabinoid of these
enforces
but we are working with some other again
with some other team across this Private
Industry who's very interested in
capturing some of these uh terpene but
we have not done so here at uh at our
research Labs at a m
will growth at different latitudes
impact cannabinoid and phytochemical in
parentheses they say turbines phenolic
acids flavonoids Etc composition and
concentration
very loaded question okay
so uh so will the photo period impact
these things is this what the question
is if the latitudinal area where the
plant is grown
okay well we know that uh
we know that uh photo appearance
sensitivity based on uh
based on the various latitudes
uh in in planting date will have an
impact on the length of of the plant has
to complete its complete life cycle
before it responds to photosynthesis uh
before it was it responded a photo
period so we would think that this is
what would have the impact uh that could
have an impact and it has to be it has
to be uh uh addressed and studied
specifically but again uh we're doing
this with Oregon State and New York and
most likely we probably will find these
details uh very soon
are male plants prefer for fire
production
uh
well for for which type of production is
there for fiber fiber okay well it
doesn't matter if it's male or female
but uh if if you're gonna grow the plant
and
because right now even to grow it for
fiber you have to create you have to do
a diocese uh uh set of plant uh that's
gonna
have almost a one-to-one male to female
and then the direction is simply at
fifty percent male pollination before
seeds begin to form in the female plant
then you come and cut it down and let it
red for the fiber so you can do the uh
extraction of the fiber so
one again that goes back to our first
question that the question you asked
earlier the idea of being able to know
that if you can uh sex sexing a plant
where you can you can know you can have
a road that is 100 male a road that's
100 female that can happen in the future
where you can grow the female for the
grain because that's very valuable and
then you can now take the uh cut these
down these uh mail for the fiber and
then still use the stem of the females
for for fiber also
but right now it's sort of a 50 50 deal
you have to kill the females to in order
to get you to get the most uh fiber off
the field
next question have you seen any
differences in flooding or drought
tolerance between cultivars
well uh I did Show a slide where
we had some plant that was under water
stress where the uh the uh at the very
early seedling stage there were Under
The Roots were basically immerse uh uh
in standing water and those spent really
barely uh recovered they recovered to a
certain extent but never reached their
full potential so therefore we're saying
that the plant uh from this just basic
observation that the plant doesn't lack
a wet root uh uh condition as far as
drought is concerned here in Northern
Alabama we have periodic drought during
the summer and uh we are taking uh uh
collecting data uh looking at uh
I've got a Time serious growth all
throughout uh those period and to see uh
and we're going to do some controlling
experiment very soon and indoor to
actually pay attention more detail to
the drought so right now we don't want
to make any speculation that that we're
observing uh response to Drought yet
next question how can we get a uniform
distribution of seeds if broadcast just
fits the birds
well and the slide that I show about uh
uh I think all my slides are still here
I probably still can go and show it if
my my screen is still being shared is
that uh when we uh let me see which
slide was it this one okay
okay
yeah what we did see we should we saw a
very good distribution we we use a basic
a willowbird to uh uh to to uh
um
[Music]
oops
this is am I still sharing screen with
you yes you're still against my screen
okay very good okay all right so this is
uh an example of uh the broadcast on the
left uh on the left side of the picture
so these to tell them the truth this we
had this uniform distribution using a
little uh really bird to uh to broadcast
the seed because even on uh planting as
such you do want your seed to have this
kind of one to two inch distance apart
so we we were satisfied with the
broadcast population it's just that you
know the uh the birds definitely were
very happy with it also
um does plasma help with decontamination
for external propagation
well we did uh
be beside during this uh hemp work with
plasma are I didn't even mention here
I'm sorry Dr Leopold uh Neil chambing
and our pathologist here did do some
work with tomato seeds uh by infecting
uh inoculate these tomato seeds with
certain uh
microorganisms probably for cerium or
something and then uh exposing them to
plasma and then and to see if the plasma
would sort of uh have a positive impact
and decreasing the proliferation of this
disease and impacting germination so he
did find some uh some kind of result I
think he's in the process of putting
together a manuscript published that uh
that outcome so we are the uh using
plasma for the purpose of sanitization
is is already something that is uh
that's out there so
for water and for other uh type of uh
biological uh but we just now actually
trying to use it in a plant world
next question uh
they're wondering if you can expand on
any political barriers issues or
positive experiences with having
oversight from the state of Alabama
oh boy I hope my state of Alabama People
are not listening
well no I'm being very very uh uh
upfront here the
State work with us
very well we we try it's if anything I'm
I'm PR I probably am the one who give
them more of a hard time and not meeting
deadline not following Direction and
they always give me the leeway to make
sure I correct my path so I'm very happy
with this Alabama State Department of
Agriculture but they are very very
stringent and I mean they've declined
certain culture bars for us to plant
here because of when they vet those uh
cultures are they don't meet a guideline
that they would like to follow here in
the state it does impinge and sort of in
a research directions sometimes uh the
biggest problem I would say and even we
just mentioned that to our state
officials just last week is that if we
can get our seeds
that we're receiving from Oregon from
New York from Kentucky much quicker
because they've already been vetted by
these uh these universities so they can
send it to us so we can start punching
early that would be great but they still
stand by their uh uh their guideline
that even though those seeds were vetted
by these other universities they too
gonna vet them before they approve them
for uh for my use
so that that's why we can't continuously
attention late here we've not been able
to plan uh early
we now have been able to receive our
seeds to be approved on time for early
planting
um
we are out of time I have a few
questions left and we can
ask a couple what basis for sufficient
levels for nutrients were used when
growing hemp
what
what basis for sufficiency levels
so we again being even is very new
it's very new to uh plant hemp to begin
the process of experimenting with him
here in the South and new or across the
U.S but there's a lot of information out
of Europe out of Australia of Israel
other places that gives us sort of uh an
indication that this is what works for
them in their area so when we say we
we're going to plan about uh uh 45
000 uh plans for fiber per uh acre or
seeds per acre or uh anywhere from five
to twenty thousand uh uh seedlings for
uh for essential oil uh CBD we're
following guideline that's already been
established by other people but even
though we would like to uh do these
experiments over ourselves here
have you observed any issues with
powdery mildew or other fungi in your
work
uh we have not we have not
and I think it's because the last few
years since we've been grown and I have
here we've been having a very dry
Summers uh not necessarily uh uh uh
We've not had much issues with uh with
mildews or uh by Polaris or the Skilling
disease that seem to have occurred but
ever so slightly so we will have to do
some uh some uh indoor experiment to uh
to do some inoculation ourselves to look
at uh
to address those issues
and the one question that I am very
curious
um also is what do you think the future
of hemp industry leans more tourism
production of grain or Fiverr or
question mark
all right question mark sounds good uh
simply because I personally well giving
a decision opinion is that we are
focusing on we are focusing on fiber as
a matter of fact there's a lot of things
that we are doing here uh with fiber
that I'm not even
privy to show you as yet uh to make all
different kind of material with the uh
with the plant even with the stems uh
and so on to improve the quality of the
Hem cream but then the fiber itself to
be able to create those type of uh
graphene plastic all those bio-based
material which can derive from this uh
high quality fiber still around the
corner my view uh uh
Louis is that I think the USDA and many
other agencies should start putting more
uh grant for sbir sdtr type of Grant
simply for entrepreneur to begin to
produce these products and and uh and
create this bio-based uh world that
we're trying to transition in
well I think I'm sorry but
pharmaceutical is very important too I'm
sure that uh the FDA uh will will have
it said so as to when these products can
begin to be officially uh be infused
into our food test
the ability well thank you so much thank
you so much uh all of you for joining us
today for this first of the welfare
series
uh please join us on February 8th for
the propagation talk by Dr Mark bridgen
uh he's going to cover all the aspects
of hemp propagation in his work in in
vitro medical propagation so thank you
so much everyone hope you have a great
day and great week
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu